this is from the daily wire says Warner
Brothers altered the video game
multiverses last week to prevent the
Scooby-Doo character Velma from calling
the police
I don't know she also worked at the
maybe she was working at a bakery too I
don't know for nearly 50 years the
Scooby-Doo franchise has shown the
Mystery Incorporated gang uh solving
crimes and alerting police to the
presence of potential criminals but
critics have recently labeled Velma a
Karen for doing precisely what had
seemed innocent enough before flashing a
wanted poster and calling the cops on
characters from across the Warner
Brothers Discovery catalog
Warner Brothers games announced last
week instead of calling the police Velma
now solves the mystery and calls the
mystery uh Inc gang and the Mystery
Machine to take the bad guys away one
petition that Drew a bear 34 signatures
lambasted Warner Brothers stating
although historically the Scooby-Doo
gang has but not always worked with the
police to catch the suspect within the
cartoons this cop car is not necessary
in the game nor does it add meaning to
her moveset whatever that means move set
set a video game chairman for decades
and especially in recent times black and
indigenous people of color around the
world have suffered under police
brutality and this cup car is ignoring
the problem of police brutality in this
day and age
it was a petition with 34 signatures for
this video game
saying that black and Indigenous people
are victims of police brutality in in
the real world and in video games or at
least they're traumatized when they see
references to the police in video games
and so for that reason she shouldn't
call the police I'm surprised they
didn't adjust the game so that instead
she calls calls a social worker you know
cause a therapist or something to come
and then in the video game we could
that's what the video game would become
like Velma uh finds the bad guy and then
calls a social worker calls a therapist
and then and then and then the video
game you actually get to see
the counseling session between the
criminal and the therapist you can you
can play it out with you know on the
game
until the therapist is just shot in the
head by the bad guy and that's the end
of the game
uh 34
signatures on a petition and they
decided to make the change
this just shows you again the the the
cultural power
the systemic power
that you have on the left
a few complaints and A change is made
meanwhile this is we're talking about
Warner Brothers
it's a
multi-multi-multi-billion dollar
Corporation
and you would think that they've got all
the money in the world and all of the
the power and resources they need to
withstand pressure from a petition of 34
people who are claiming to be upset
because they saw something in a video
game
and they could withstand it but they
choose not to
because if you're on the left
you know your one vote culturally
speaking counts for like a million
you count for a million people
get 34 people together it's 34 million
people crying out in a society Rife with
anti-religious ideologies like the ones
we hear from the left on a daily basis
it can be incredibly challenging to
ground oneself in what we know to be
true and good to keep from descending
and to destroy into distrust frustration
or even hatred that's why I find God's
peace every day through prayer and
meditation with hallow hallow is the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
U.S and the number one Catholic app in
the world it's rooted in Catholic
tradition but it's an amazing resource
for any Christian looking to dive deeper
into their prayer life hallow has
prayers meditations to guide you
throughout your entire day morning
tonight some of the most popular prayers
include the daily Rosary Gospel reading
and daily Psalm with Bishop Barron the
Bible in the year with with father Mike
Schmitz is also there meditations for
Sleep kids prayers and much more Hello
helps me find peace and calm throughout
the day helps me sleep better lower my
anxiety levels and teach my kids not to
be terrible humans which is also
important so let Halo help you find your
peace and strength throughout the day go
to hallow.com
and get an extended three-month free
trial during which you'll have access to
all five thousand plus meditations and
prayers that's hello.com Matt Walsh for
three months free reclaim your piece in
this crazy world download hello today
in has to say nothing of the fact that
why are there adults playing a
Scooby-Doo video game in the first place
I read through some of these tweets and
there aren't many that were complaining
about this because but again it doesn't
need to be met it's like just one person
can complain and it'll bring a
corporation a billion dollar Corporation
to its knees
um but the few people complaining seem
to be adults as far as I can tell
who not only are claimed to be
traumatized by a cop car interview again
but are playing a Scooby-Doo video game
to begin with
that's the real problem here
and by the way one thing I'll say about
adults playing video games this is kind
of a side note okay a sidebar here
because I know that I've I've been hard
on on grown-up gamers in the past and I
always upset The Gaming Community
well it's not really a community just
because you all like playing video games
doesn't make a community but still I
always upset them when I talk about this
and so I do want to acknowledge one
thing because this I think this is
important to acknowledge
that if you can do it in moderation
right play video games it is fine it's
just it's just Recreation it's
relaxation whatever
now I think playing a Scooby-Doo video
game even in moderation is ridiculous
and embarrassing but it's not going to
hurt you if you're if in moderation like
every once in a while you like to sit
down and play a video game whatever uh
and it isn't all that different because
the compare when I talk about this the
the uh rejoined or the rebuttal
from The Gamers is well you like you
watch football what's the difference
now it is a little bit different
but but I get the point
you know
um yeah it's it's a similar sort of
thing
now I watch basically one football game
a week all the way through and that's
only from September to January and I'll
watch other games on occasion you know
I'll check some scores here and there
that kind of thing but religiously I
will watch one game a week for about 17
weeks of the year a few more weeks if
the Ravens don't suck this year but it
looks like they probably do uh there are
people who will watch football literally
all weekend long they watch college on
Saturday they watch professional on
Sunday and they watch all the games they
just sit there that's all they do
they're our dads whose families lose
them for the entire football season like
the weekends are gone all all of
football season because both Saturday
and Sunday are completely dominated by
the dad's desire to just sit on his ass
and watch football
um like 24 hours of football every
weekend and there are people whose
fandom consumes them they they take it
very very seriously way too seriously
they get into I just saw another I think
it was that probably I'm assuming it was
at a Jets game but maybe it wasn't
um
and on a violent altercation at a
football game people go to games and
they get into or they go to sports bars
and yeah there's drinking involved also
but they get into actual violent
altercations with other fans about whose
team is best and they start they start
trying to kill each other over that's
how seriously they take it all of this
is childish and sad
and it represents a recreational
activity
which has become a lifestyle
and that is where video games I think we
should say are a problem
that's why I don't like the phrase the
gamer Community when you're referring to
it as a community now you've made it
into a lifestyle Choice it's like your
life revolves around it
um that that is the issue and when we're
adults
Our Lives should not revolve around
Recreation
it should not revolve around our
favorite recreational activity Our Lives
should not revolve around entertainment
even our kids lives shouldn't revolve
around entertainment we should have we
should we should uh raise our kids to
have it richer more interesting more
vibrant lives than that
that's the I know you're uh craving some
more Matt Walsh show content while I
have some great news for you if you head
over to dailywire.com And subscribe now
you can watch or listen to my full show
you can also listen to my podcast on
Spotify Apple podcast or wherever you
get your podcast I'll see you there